You're juggling a lot, but you can still squeeze in a financial plan. With the Northwestern Mutual Financial Advisor as your partner, it's not only possible, it's personalized. So if you're tying the knot, closing on a house, or welcoming a little one, you'll be ready for whatever life tosses your way. It's the right time to feel less stressed and more certain. That's a better way to money. Let's get started at nm.com, the Northwestern Mutual Life Insurance Company, Milwaukee, Wisconsin. Millions of Americans who once spent their days in offices are now entering their fourth month of full-time telework, commuting to their new desks in their basements or corners of living rooms, often while also trying to take care of children whose schools, summer camps, and daycares are closed.
你正忙得不可开交，但依然可以挤出时间制定财务计划。有西北互助人寿保险公司的理财顾问作为你的合作伙伴，这不仅是可能的，而且是量身定制的。因此，无论你是步入婚姻殿堂、购置房产，还是喜迎新生命，你都能为生活抛给你的任何挑战做好准备。现在正是减轻压力、增强信心的好时机。这是一种更好的理财方式。让我们从 nm.com 开始，西北互助人寿保险公司，威斯康星州密尔沃基。数百万曾经在办公室工作的美国人，现在正进入全职远程办公的第四个月，他们通勤到地下室或客厅角落里的新办公桌前，往往还要同时照顾那些学校、夏令营和日托中心都已关闭的孩子们。
Other workers, meanwhile, are outfitting themselves with masks and hand sanitizer and cautiously returning to their long empty cubicles. In addition to being a public health crisis, the COVID-19 pandemic has proven to be a forced, unplanned experiment in mass telework and work-family conflict. How is it turning out for American office workers? Have we been more or less productive? And what might be the effects on the future of work? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association.
与此同时，其他员工则戴上口罩和洗手液，小心翼翼地回到早已空无一人的隔间。除了是一场公共卫生危机，新冠疫情还被证明是一场被迫的、未经计划的大规模远程办公和工作与家庭冲突的实验。这对美国办公室职员来说结果如何？我们的生产力是提高了还是降低了？这对未来的工作会有什么影响？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》。
I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Kristen Shockley, an associate professor of psychology at the University of Georgia. Dr. Shockley has spent her career studying the University of Georgia. intersection of work and family life. She's conducted research on how employees balance work and family demands, how work family conflict affects people's health, and how dual career couples navigate work and family roles. When the COVID-19 crisis hit, she realized that the upheaval caused by school and office closures made those questions even more pressing, and she set out to investigate how workers are adjusting. Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Shockley. Thank you for having me.
我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是佐治亚大学心理学副教授克里斯汀·肖克利博士。肖克利博士的职业生涯一直致力于研究工作与家庭生活的交集。她对员工如何平衡工作与家庭需求、工作与家庭冲突如何影响人们的健康，以及双职工夫妻如何处理工作与家庭角色进行了研究。当新冠疫情爆发时，她意识到学校和办公室关闭所带来的动荡使这些问题变得更加紧迫，于是她着手调查员工们是如何适应的。欢迎来到《心理学谈话》，肖克利博士。谢谢你邀请我。
You received a rapid response grant from the National Science Foundation to look at how workers are coping with the abrupt transition to telework during the COVID-19 shutdowns. Can you talk about why you thought it was important to do this research now, how you're doing it, and what questions are you asking? Yeah, so when, I think it was March 13th, when we started realizing that a lot of people were going to be transitioning to remote work, I contacted one of my longtime collaborators at the University of South Florida, Tammy Allen, and said, should we try to get a rapid grant to study this, just because this is sort of a natural experiment like we've never seen before with so many people moving into remote work. So we proposed a study to the National Science Foundation
你获得了美国国家科学基金会的快速响应资助，以研究员工如何应对新冠疫情期间向远程办公的突然过渡。你能谈谈为什么你认为现在进行这项研究很重要，你是如何进行的，以及你提出了哪些问题吗？是的，我想是在3月13日，当我们开始意识到很多人将要过渡到远程工作时，我联系了我在南佛罗里达大学的长期合作者塔米·艾伦，并说，我们是否应该尝试申请一笔快速资助来研究这个问题，因为这就像我们从未见过的自然实验，有这么多人转向远程工作。所以我们向国家科学基金会提交了一项研究建议。
and I think we wrote it up within eight days and heard back seven days later that it was funded. So the whole process has been very rapid. And we set out really to explore best practices in remote work because there's been a good amount of research on it, but it's largely cross-sectional data comparing non-telecommuters to telecommuters. So what we wanted to dig into is within a sample of people who are all telecommuting, where you don't have some of these selection effects like managers picking people they want to telecommute.
我想我们在八天内就写好了申请，七天后就收到了获得资助的通知。所以整个过程非常迅速。我们真正着手探索的是远程工作的最佳实践，因为虽然已经有相当多的相关研究，但大多是横截面数据，比较的是非远程办公者和远程办公者。所以我们想深入研究的是，在一个全员远程办公的样本中，排除掉一些选择性效应，比如经理挑选他们想要远程办公的人。
When everybody's in the kind of same situation, what are factors that vary day-to-day that might impact people's well-being as well as their productivity? So we just thought it was really just an unprecedented time to study these important issues and then be able to say we have some evidence-based recommendations moving forward to disseminate broadly. Do you have any results yet that you could talk about? So we just wrapped data collection up on Saturday. So we haven't analyzed anything formally. I did dig into the data a little bit just to look at some descriptive things. a few of the interesting things I saw where we asked people, and I should say the entire sample,
当每个人都处于同一种情况下，哪些因素会随时间变化并可能影响人们的幸福感和生产力？所以我们认为这是一个研究这些重要问题的绝佳时机，并能够提出一些基于证据的建议，以便广泛传播。你有什么可以分享的结果吗？我们刚刚在周六结束了数据收集。所以我们还没有进行任何正式的分析。我确实深入研究了一下数据，看了一些描述性的东西。我看到的一些有趣的事情是，我们询问了人们，我应该说整个样本，
they're all working fully remote, but we're not working remote very much at all, 10% or less before COVID. So we asked them, while COVID remains a public health threat, and what percent at the time would you want to stay working remote? And the vast majority said 100%. Wow. Yeah. I mean, I think it was 90% of the samples said 100%. That's pretty amazing. Yeah, that speaks to the fact that people are saying, you know, I don't want the risk. And even if this arrangement's not perfect, it's worth it to not, you know, expose potential exposure. We also asked once COVID is no longer as big of a threat, what percentage of the time would you like to work remote?
他们都在全职远程工作，但在新冠疫情之前，他们几乎没有远程工作过，比例在10%或以下。所以我们问他们，在新冠疫情仍然是公共卫生威胁的情况下，你希望有多少比例的时间保持远程工作？绝大多数人回答100%。哇。是的，我的意思是，我想样本中有90%的人回答了100%。这太令人惊讶了。是的，这说明人们在说，你知道，我不想冒风险。即使这种安排并不完美，为了不暴露在潜在的风险中也是值得的。我们还问，一旦新冠疫情不再是一个巨大的威胁，你希望有多少比例的时间远程工作？
And there we saw a very spread out distribution. So the most common responses were 100 and zero, but then it was really. out, really spread out in between, and the average was 46%. What that's telling me is, you know, some people are liking it, some aren't. I think for most people, they're seeing working remote some at the time would be nice, but this 100% has some downsides, probably largely in terms of, you know, social isolation, not feeling like you get out of a house ever. So let's shift gears for a minute to talk about telework more broadly.
在那里我们看到了一个非常分散的分布。最常见的回答是100%和0%，但中间的分布非常广，平均值为46%。这告诉我的情况是，你知道，有些人喜欢它，有些人不喜欢。我认为对大多数人来说，他们认为部分时间远程工作会很好，但100%远程工作有一些缺点，可能主要是在社会孤立方面，感觉永远无法走出家门。那么让我们换个话题，谈谈更广泛的远程办公。
Even before the pandemic, more than 26 million Americans, were working remotely, at least part of the time, which is about 16% of the total U.S. labor force of 165 million. How well was that working? There's kind of an idea in the popular imagination that people slack off and they're less productive when they telework. Does the research back that up? Yeah, there is that huge perception. And we look at the headlines are kind of all over the place with is teleworking a good or a bad thing, you know, pre-COVID. And actually the data really don't suggest that people typically slack off. If anything, they show that people are the same or more productive. We don't have a lot of good experiments, you know, which is the best way to really disentangle
甚至在疫情之前，就有超过2600万美国人至少部分时间在远程工作，这大约占美国1.65亿劳动力总数的16%。那时的效果如何？在大众的想象中，有一种观点认为人们在远程办公时会偷懒，生产力会下降。研究支持这种说法吗？是的，确实有那种巨大的认知。我们看到关于远程办公是好是坏的头条新闻到处都是，你知道，在新冠疫情之前。实际上，数据并不表明人们通常会偷懒。如果有的话，它们显示人们的生产力相同或更高。我们没有很多好的实验，你知道，这是真正理清
is it teleworking that's causing you to be more or less productive. But there was one really solid experiment out there. And they found it was in a call center and they found that the workers who worked from home made significantly more calls every day. They actually worked longer hours. But the quality of their calls were just as high as they were before. So suggesting people are more efficient, I think, from home, which is, in a lot of cases, I would say largely because you're not being interrupted by coworkers in the noisy environment of the office. Now, of course, COVID's a little bit different because people have kids at home, so they may have interruptions if they wouldn't under a normal remote work arrangement where they would have child care.
是远程办公导致你生产力更高还是更低的最佳方式。但有一个非常扎实的实验。他们发现是在一个呼叫中心，他们发现居家办公的员工每天拨打的电话数量明显更多。他们实际上工作的时间更长。但他们的通话质量和以前一样高。这表明人们在家办公效率更高，我认为，在很多情况下，这主要是因为你不会被办公室嘈杂环境中的同事打断。当然，新冠疫情有点不同，因为人们有孩子在家，所以如果他们没有像正常远程工作安排那样有托儿服务，他们可能会受到干扰。
Before the COVID-19 pandemic, some early adopters, including Best Buy, IBM and Yachter, were reversing policies that allowed employees to telecommute. They cited leadership changes in a growing need for a creative collaboration. Do you think that these companies will continue on that path once the emergency is over? Yeah, those are really interesting, especially Best Buy, because they had been really progressive, actually, in allowing people to work however or wherever. And then I was surprised to see them roll that back because the data actually, at least the data that was published suggested that was working. But I think moving forward, based on what I'm seeing, just in informal discussions as well as in headlines, I think a lot of companies are going to become much more open to remote work.
在新冠疫情之前，一些早期采用者，包括百思买、IBM和雅虎，正在撤销允许员工远程办公的政策。他们提到了领导层的变动和对创造性协作日益增长的需求。你认为这些公司在紧急情况结束后会继续走这条路吗？是的，这些非常有趣，尤其是百思买，因为他们实际上在允许人们以任何方式或在任何地方工作方面非常进步。然后我很惊讶地看到他们撤回了这一点，因为数据实际上，至少已发表的数据表明那是有效的。但我认为展望未来，根据我所看到的，无论是在非正式讨论中还是在头条新闻中，我认为很多公司将变得对远程工作更加开放。
I think it's going to be important for recruitment and retaining people in the workforce now that a lot of people have gotten a taste for it. I think a lot of employees are going to sort of demand it and want a workforce to allow that. And there's also a lot of benefits from a cost-saving standpoint. You don't have to have as much office space so you can save on real estate. And you can also, if you have a fully remote workforce, you can recruit from anywhere in the world, which really puts you an advantage in trying to get top talent. So I'm projecting, you know, there's no way really to know, but I think we will see more of a shift to remote work moving forward. Is teleworking equally good for everyone? Is there some kind of a profile of the person who thrives and the person who really struggles?
我认为这对招聘和留住劳动力很重要，因为现在很多人已经尝到了甜头。我认为很多员工会要求这样做，并希望劳动力能够实现这一点。而且从节省成本的角度来看，也有很多好处。你不需要那么多的办公空间，所以你可以节省房地产成本。而且，如果你拥有全职远程办公的员工队伍，你可以在世界任何地方招聘，这在争取顶尖人才方面确实让你处于优势。所以我预测，你知道，虽然没有办法真正知道，但我认为未来我们会看到更多向远程工作的转变。远程办公对每个人都同样好吗？是否存在某种适合远程办公的人和真正挣扎的人的画像？
Yeah, that's a great question. And that was one of the things we're trying to uncover in our grant and our rapid grant because there's hardly any research out there at all on the topic. I think there's one study that looked at personality. But other than that, there's a lot to be done. So we're exploring different personality variables in our dataset. We're also exploring things like family structure, the way that you like to manage work in family. Because if you're someone who really likes to keep them separate, obviously working from home, does not allow you to do that.
是的，这是一个很好的问题。这也是我们在我们的资助和快速资助中试图揭示的事情之一，因为关于这个主题几乎没有任何研究。我想有一项研究关注了人格。但除此之外，还有很多工作要做。所以我们正在探索我们数据集中的不同人格变量。我们还在探索家庭结构、你喜欢管理工作和家庭的方式等因素。因为如果你是一个真正喜欢将它们分开的人，显然在家工作并不能让你做到这一点。
So we're predicting it's going to be more of a challenge for people like that. We're also exploring aspects of the physical office at home. I think that makes a really big difference in how well and comfortable people are telecommuting. If you have a setup where your chair's not quite right, you don't have the multiple monitors, you're just not comfortable. And I think it's hard to be productive and enjoy teleworking in that arrangement. So there's some basic ideas out there in the literature, but that's something we're hoping to really hone in on with this new data.
所以我们预测这对这样的人来说将是一个更大的挑战。我们还在探索家庭物理办公室的各个方面。我认为这在人们远程办公的舒适度和效果上产生了很大的影响。如果你有一个椅子不太合适的设置，你没有多台显示器，你只是不舒服。我认为在这种安排下很难保持高效并享受远程办公。所以文献中存在一些基本的想法，但这正是我们希望通过这些新数据真正深入研究的内容。
I remember hiring my first teleworking staff for more than 15 years ago, and the only ways we could stay connected were by email and the telephone. But now there are applications like Teams and Google Hangouts and Zoom. Was telework already on the upswing before the pandemic, notwithstanding the rollbacks that I mentioned just a minute ago? Yeah, so it seems to be that the trend is, you know, more and more people teleworking. and people starting to take advantage of some of these technologies you're talking about.
我记得15年前我雇佣我的第一批远程办公员工时，我们保持联系的唯一方式是通过电子邮件和电话。但现在有了Teams、Google Hangouts和Zoom这样的应用程序。尽管我刚才提到的撤销政策，远程办公在疫情之前是否已经在上升？是的，趋势似乎是，你知道，越来越多的人在远程办公。人们开始利用你所说的这些技术。
And what the academic literature was suggesting pre-COVID was it's best to use the most, what they call high fidelity technology that you can use. So that would be, you know, use Zoom or Skype or Teams over the phone. Because when you see people face-to-face, or not, I guess not face-face, but when you can see people's face while you're speaking, you know, that's supposed to mimic more of a face-to-face interaction. And so that was sort of the common advice that I had been giving to people. But what's been interesting during the pandemic is this concept of Zoom fatigue.
学术文献在新冠疫情前建议的是，最好使用他们所说的你能使用的最高保真度技术。所以那将是，你知道，使用Zoom或Skype或Teams而不是电话。因为当你面对面看到人们时，或者不是，我想不是面对面，但当你说话时能看到人们的脸，你知道，那应该模仿更多的面对面互动。所以这大概是我一直给人们的常见建议。但疫情期间有趣的是这种“Zoom疲劳”的概念。
Right. I mean, a lot of discussion about it. I'm experiencing it myself. So that had not been researched at all. So that's something else that we're exploring in our grant because we have daily reports of what technology people use and how much during, you know, how frequently they use the different technologies throughout each day. So we're going to try to predict sort of what's the opposite. level of using these technologies because I think in some cases they're really useful, but maybe we were starting to overuse them when things could have just been a quick phone call
对。我的意思是，有很多关于它的讨论。我自己也正在经历它。所以这根本没有被研究过。所以这是我们在资助中探索的另一件事，因为我们有关于人们使用什么技术以及频率的每日报告，你知道，他们每天使用不同技术的频率。所以我们将尝试预测某种程度的平衡，因为我认为在某些情况下它们非常有用，但也许当事情本可以通过一个快速电话解决时，我们开始过度使用它们，
and we started relying on on Zoom or teams. That's interesting. Yeah, it'll be interesting to see what comes out there. In a recent review of the research, you talked about how some people are segmenters and others are blenders and that segmenters may find remote work more difficult. Can you explain what that all means? Yeah, so that's the concept of boundary management strategy. So individuals exist on this continuum.
而我们开始依赖Zoom或Teams。这很有趣。是的，看看会有什么结果会很有趣。在最近的一项研究综述中，你谈到了有些人是“分割者”，而另一些人是“整合者”，并且分割者可能会发现远程工作更困难。你能解释一下这一切意味着什么吗？是的，这就是边界管理策略的概念。所以个人存在于这个连续体上。
So at one end, you have the segmenters. And these are the people who really like to keep work and family separate. So they're not talking about work when they get home. They're not talking about their personal life at work. They're not going to have pictures on their desk at work. They're just really think of them as two separate domains. And then the other end, you have the integrators. And they're the exact opposite.
所以在一端，你有分割者。这些人真的喜欢把工作和家庭分开。所以他们回家时不谈论工作。他们在工作中不谈论个人生活。他们不会在办公桌上放照片。他们只是真的把它们看作两个独立的领域。然后在另一端，你有整合者。他们正好相反。
You know, they're the people that are constantly while at work, juggling things from home. They might get home and be really likely to work later in the evening, checking emails all the time. And so it's just really a personal preference of what strategy people works best for them to manage working family. So when you're working from home, then you have this added challenge of if you're a segmenter, it's really hard to keep those things separate when they're occurring in the same location. So advice we give to people in that situation is try to have a separate room that's really designated as your workspace that's only used for that. And it's, which, you know, is easier set than done depending on where you live and the kind of
你知道，他们是在工作中不断处理家庭事务的人。他们回家后可能真的很有可能在晚上晚些时候工作，一直查看电子邮件。所以这只是人们为了管理工作和家庭而采取的策略的个人偏好。所以当你在家工作时，如果你是一个分割者，当这些事情发生在同一个地点时，保持它们分开就真的很难。所以我们给处于这种情况的人的建议是，尝试有一个真正指定为你的工作空间的独立房间，只用于此目的。而且，你知道，这说起来容易做起来难，取决于你住在哪里以及你拥有的
space you have. But that's the ideal situation. And to have a door so that you can close that so your family members know, okay, when that door is closed, that means this person is, I have to think of them as not here. So those are some kind of tricks to try to make it feel more segmented. What about differences between managers and line employees when it comes to teleworking? Is it, is it harder to be a remote manager? And how do employees react to having a boss who teleworks?
空间。但这是理想的情况。并且要有一扇门，这样你可以关上它，让你的家人知道，好的，当那扇门关上时，这意味着这个人，我必须认为他们不在这里。所以这些是一些试图让它感觉更像分割的技巧。那么经理和一线员工在远程办公方面有什么区别吗？远程管理是否更难？员工对有一个远程办公的老板有什么反应？
Yeah, that's another thing where there's not very much research on the topic at all. There's one study about bosses who telework and comparing them, their relationship with their subordinates who are in office and their subordinates who are also teleworking. And the other comparison is managers who are in the office. So you have kind of these four different quadrants. And not surprisingly, that the relationship. relationships are a bit more strained with the managers who are working remote. They don't explore why, but my hypothesis would be they're just not having as many
是的，这是另一件几乎没有任何研究的主题。有一项关于远程办公的老板的研究，比较了他们与在办公室的下属以及同样远程办公的下属的关系。另一个比较是办公室里的经理。所以你有这四个不同的象限。不出所料，与远程办公的经理的关系稍微紧张一些。他们没有探讨原因，但我的假设是他们只是没有那么多的
interactions with people. You don't have the chance just when you're walking by someone to kind of have that informal back and forth in the hallways. So I think there are some challenges there. And another thing we set out to explore in the grant was what are actually the best practices for managers who are telecommuting? because there's a lot of theoretical discussion of that sort of ideas put forth in the academic literature, but we don't have a lot of actual data to back it up.
与人的互动。当你走过某人身边时，你没有机会在走廊里进行那种非正式的来回交流。所以我认为那里确实存在一些挑战。我们在资助中着手探索的另一件事是，远程办公的经理的最佳实践到底是什么？因为学术文献中有很多关于这种想法的理论讨论，但我们没有很多实际数据来支持它。
So that was something, that was a core part of our study, was to say, well, you know, what kind of things are managers doing on a daily basis when people are having a good day and what kind of things are they doing that sort of contribute to people not having a great day? So that's another question, which I hope to have data to be able to speak more directly to it in the future. A lot of questions out there. They really are, and that's really why we did this grant because it's just amazing how little we have actual empirical evidence for. The American Psychological Association conducted a stress in America survey last month that found nearly half of parents with children under age 18 at home said their stress levels related to the coronavirus pandemic were high, with managing the kids online learning a significant source of stress for many. what can people do to make this work, life, family balancing act easier?
所以这是我们研究的核心部分，即说，好吧，你知道，当人们度过美好的一天时，经理们每天都在做什么样的事情，而当人们度过糟糕的一天时，他们又在做什么样的事情？所以这是另一个问题，我希望将来有数据能够更直接地说明它。有很多问题。确实如此，这正是我们进行这项资助的原因，因为我们拥有的实际经验证据之少令人惊讶。美国心理学会上个月进行了一项“美国压力”调查，发现近一半家里有18岁以下孩子的父母表示，他们与新冠疫情相关的压力水平很高，管理孩子的在线学习对许多人来说是一个重要的压力来源。人们可以做些什么来让这种工作、生活、家庭的平衡行为更容易？
I feel like that's a million dollar question right now. Right? Yeah, I mean, it's such an unprecedented thing because most of what we know about teleworking comes from assuming people have kids in school or childcare during the time when they're working. So I can say I have another data set not related to my grant where we got data from couples who were both working and continuing to work during COVID, but had young kids who were at home and their child care,
我觉得那是现在价值百万美元的问题。对吧？是的，我的意思是，这是一件前所未有的事情，因为我们所知道的大部分关于远程办公的知识都来自于假设人们在工作时孩子在学校或托儿所。所以我可以说，我还有另一个与我的资助无关的数据集，我们从在新冠疫情期间都在工作并继续工作的夫妻那里获得了数据，但他们有年幼的孩子在家，他们的托儿服务，
either daycare or their nanny, was no longer coming. And we were exploring, what are people doing? What are the strategies to better manage this? And so we asked them a lot of open-ended questions. And I've been reading through those. Again, that data collection is just finished recently, so I don't have a full analysis. But as I'm reading through it,
无论是日托还是保姆，都不再来了。我们正在探索，人们在做什么？更好地管理这一点的策略是什么？所以我们问了他们很多开放式的问题。我一直在阅读这些问题。同样，数据收集只是最近才完成，所以我没有完整的分析。但在阅读过程中，
I'm seeing a lot of people engaging in a lot of very detailed, detailed scheduling with their part. Right. Yeah. Yeah, it's thinking about, okay, let's take the day. Let's break it up into chunks. This is my portion of uninterrupted time. And then we switch off and I have primary responsibility for the kids.
我看到很多人正在与他们的伴侣进行非常详细的日程安排。对吧。是的。是的，它在考虑，好的，让我们把这一天分开。让我们把它分成几块。这是我不受干扰的时间部分。然后我们切换，我对孩子们负主要责任。
And then we switch back to the other spouses and we are both working with their young kids when they're napping. And then some people, a lot of people were saying, you know, we're waking up earlier and going to bed later to try to make this work. But to the extent to which that's a long-term strategy, I'm guessing not. I'm assuming there's going to be a lot of burnout. And we have measured that in the data set. So I'm interested to see if these different strategies that people use link differently to that. But I think the best thing is really being proactive, not just winging it, but trying to see what you can do to feel like it's fair within your relationship to the extent if you both are able with flexible jobs to help with the child care. And your kids will cooperate.
然后我们切换回另一位配偶，当孩子们在午睡时，我们都在和他们一起工作。然后有些人，很多人说，你知道，我们起得更早，睡得更晚，试图让这一切奏效。但就这是否是一个长期策略而言，我猜不是。我假设会有很多倦怠。我们已经在数据集中测量了这一点。所以我很想看看人们使用的这些不同策略是否与此有不同的联系。但我认为最好的事情是真正主动，而不是仅仅随心所欲，而是尝试看看你能做些什么来让你在关系中感到公平，如果你们俩都能通过灵活的工作来帮助照顾孩子。而且你的孩子们会配合。
So when it's mommy time, it's only mommy time. Yeah, right. That's the other layer of it. And also just thinking about the burnout aspect of it. So recognizing when you're at a point when you're about to break. So saying, okay, I've got to, we've got to switch something up because I need a day just to myself. I think that's a really big thing that's getting overlooked in this pandemic is just the loss of sort of me time and the loss of. of ability to practice self-care. And I think it's important for people to figure out the way that they can do that in the context of sheltering at home and the current pandemic. Yeah, are you looking at people taking vacation time as part of this study as well? That seems to be a real challenge for a lot of us. Like, why would I take time off?
所以当是妈妈时间时，就只是妈妈时间。是的，没错。这是它的另一层。还有就是考虑它的倦怠方面。所以要认识到当你处于即将崩溃的边缘时。所以说，好的，我必须，我们必须改变一些事情，因为我需要一天只属于我自己的时间。我认为这是这场疫情中被忽视的一件大事，就是某种“自我时间”的丧失和丧失。练习自我保健的能力。我认为人们找出在居家避难和当前疫情背景下可以做到这一点的方法很重要。是的，你也在研究中关注人们休假的情况吗？这对我们很多人来说似乎是一个真正的挑战。比如，我为什么要休假？
I can't go anywhere. Yeah, so we did ask how many PTO days people had and how many they planned on using. And so we do have that data. But it was more in the context of using it. We just asked, are they going to use it? We didn't ask why. I've seen a lot of people talking about it in the open-ended reports, more about using it because they have no other option for child care and being really stressed about that.
我哪儿也去不了。是的，所以我们确实问了人们有多少带薪休假天数以及他们计划使用多少。所以我们确实有那些数据。但它更多是在使用它的背景下。我们只是问，他们会使用它吗？我们没有问为什么。我在开放式报告中看到很多人在谈论它，更多是因为他们没有其他托儿选择，并为此感到非常压力。
Like, I don't know what we're going to do when these 10 days run up. But we didn't get anything about the vacation aspect, which is really, really interesting because usually people have that kind of break. And now it's tough to figure out what you would do with that time. There have been media reports about how the burden of balancing work and caregiving is disproportionately falling on women, and some have suggested that the pandemic might set women back in the workplace for years to come. I understand you have another study going on now looking at how dual career couples are navigating, I'm wondering what you think and what your research might suggest about how this time will affect women in particular and whether these fears are justified.
比如，我不知道当这10天用完后我们该怎么办。但我们没有得到任何关于度假方面的信息，这真的非常非常有趣，因为通常人们有那种休息时间。而现在很难弄清楚你会用那段时间做什么。媒体报道称，平衡工作和照料的负担不成比例地落在女性身上，一些人建议疫情可能会使女性在职场上倒退多年。我知道你现在正在进行另一项研究，观察双职工夫妻是如何处理的，我想知道你怎么看，以及你的研究可能暗示这段时间将如何特别影响女性，以及这些担忧是否合理。
Yeah, so the data set that we have is all couples where both are working and both have young children at home and child care has been disrupted. And so we have these open-ended reports that people are about what they're doing to manage right now. And we haven't, we're still in the process of coding. Then we've gone through many iterations. We're almost finished with it. But I don't have actual frequencies to tell you at this point. But I can say just in my reading of these and we have 317 couples. So it's quite a bit of descriptions.
是的，我们拥有的数据集都是夫妻双方都在工作，并且家里都有年幼的孩子，而且托儿服务受到了干扰。所以我们有这些关于人们现在正在做什么来管理的开放式报告。我们还没有，我们还在编码过程中。我们已经经历了多次迭代。我们快完成了。但我目前没有实际的频率来告诉你。但我可以说，仅仅在我阅读这些内容时，我们有317对夫妻。所以有很多描述。
scenarios here. A lot of what I'm seeing is genderized. So a lot of it is in the heterosexual couples, which is the bulk of our sampler, you're seeing the woman is the one scaling back more. A lot of the comments say things like, well, I make less, so it makes more sense for me to scale back. And if you think about that from a bigger picture in society, we know we have this pay gap. Well, then when you're making decisions like this based on pay, then it's sort of this vicious cycle, right. So then women are, okay, well, I'm the one who makes less, so I'm the one who's scaling back more. And then that could have some long-term career repercussions. So I do think that the disproportionate division of labor that we see with child care and household labor is being
这里的情况。我看到的很多东西都是性别化的。所以很多是在异性恋夫妻中，这是我们样本的大部分，你看到女性是缩减更多的人。很多评论说，比如，好吧，我赚得少，所以我缩减规模更有意义。如果你从社会的大局来看，我们知道我们有这种薪酬差距。好吧，当你基于薪酬做出这样的决定时，这就像是一种恶性循环，对吧。所以女性是，好吧，我是赚得少的那个人，所以我缩减更多。这可能会产生一些长期的职业影响。所以我确实认为我们在托儿和家务劳动中看到的不成比例的劳动分工正在
exacerbated right now by the pandemic. And as part of that, do you find that men and women experience work family conflict differently? Yeah, so that's a good question. And I had done a study that was published in the journal with Applied Psychology in 2017, it was a meta-analysis. So we aggregated the results of 350 primary studies. So we had this huge sample size of over 200,000 people. And we looked at gender differences in work-family conflict because people usually think women have more conflict. And we actually found no to very, very small gender differences, which was a pretty surprising finding, I think, to us and to a lot of people.
现在被疫情加剧。作为其中的一部分，你是否发现男性和女性对工作与家庭冲突的体验不同？是的，这是一个好问题。我曾做过一项研究，发表在2017年的《应用心理学杂志》上，那是一项荟萃分析。所以我们汇总了350项主要研究的结果。所以我们有超过20万人的巨大样本量。我们研究了工作与家庭冲突中的性别差异，因为人们通常认为女性有更多的冲突。我们实际上发现没有到非常非常小的性别差异，我认为这对我们和很多人来说是一个相当令人惊讶的发现。
That's all based on the way that it's typically measured in the academic world. So that would be questions to measure work-family conflict. The questions would be things like, my work interferes with my family life more than I would like. And then you answer it on a like-ard scale from strongly disagree to strongly agree. And we found no differences there. But what we couldn't speak to in that data set is maybe for men and women, you know, the anchors have different meanings.
这完全基于学术界通常测量它的方式。所以那将是测量工作与家庭冲突的问题。问题会是这样的，我的工作干扰了我的家庭生活，超过了我想要的程度。然后你在李克特量表上从强烈不同意到强烈同意回答它。我们发现那里没有差异。但我们在那个数据集中无法说明的是，也许对男性和女性来说，锚点有不同的含义。
Yeah. So it could, you know, women are so socialized to think about work family issues, I think much more than men. And so they kind of expect to have to deal with this issue. And so the same situation for a man and a woman might be appraised as just an agree on the scale for a woman where it's a strongly agree for a man. And you really speak to that with the nature of our data. But we're doing some follow-up research to try to disentangle it more. One study we're doing is a lab study where we brought men and women not going to. couples, but just separately men and women that were all parents into our lab. And they read
是的。所以它可能，你知道，女性被社会化得更多地考虑工作家庭问题，我认为比男性多得多。所以她们有点期望必须处理这个问题。所以对男人和女人来说同样的情况可能会被评估为女性量表上的“同意”，而对男人来说是“强烈同意”。你真的用我们数据的性质说明了这一点。但我们正在做一些后续研究，试图更深入地解开它。我们正在做的一项研究是一项实验室研究，我们将男性和女性带入我们的实验室，不是夫妻，而是分开的男性和女性，他们都是父母。他们阅读
these stories about work family conflict situations that we had based off of actual real stories we got from people in a previous study. And then we measured their physiological reactions. So we have this watch called the Empatica Watch, which measures your galvanic skin response and your heart rate and a couple other things, which are indications of stress. We also measured their cortisol levels to see if there's a physiological difference. And we didn't find anything with cortisol. We're still working on analyzing the other data. But then we asked, how do you think you would feel in this situation and a variety of different emotions like guilty, angry, irritated? And by a huge margin, the women reported much higher emotional reactions. Yeah. Right. Especially guilt.
这些关于工作家庭冲突情况的故事，我们是基于我们在之前研究中从人们那里得到的实际真实故事。然后我们测量了他们的生理反应。所以我们有这种叫Empatica的手表，它测量你的皮肤电反应和心率以及其他几件事，这些是压力的迹象。我们还测量了他们的皮质醇水平，看看是否有生理差异。我们没有发现皮质醇有任何发现。我们仍在努力分析其他数据。但然后我们问，你认为你在这种情况下会有什么感觉，以及各种不同的情绪，比如内疚、愤怒、恼火？结果女性报告了高出许多的强烈情绪反应。是的。对。尤其是内疚。
That was the one that stood up the most. I was waiting for that. Yeah. To me, that suggests that there is, you know, maybe they are reporting the same level of conflict, but I think that women are internalizing it and letting it affect their well-being more so than men are. But we need to do a little bit more research before I firmly say that. But the follow-up stuff we're doing now is just to try to see, is this null effect, this no difference really true? Or is it sort of coming out the way we measure things? A few high-profile companies, including Facebook and Twitter, have announced that they're going to let employees continue to work at home permanently, even after the end of this emergency. Do you think we're going to see a significant permanent increase in the number of
那是表现最突出的一个。我一直在等那个。是的。对我来说，这表明，你知道，也许她们报告了相同水平的冲突，但我认为女性正在内化它，并让它比男性更多地影响她们的幸福感。但在我坚定地说出来之前，我们需要做更多的研究。但我们现在正在做的后续工作只是试图看看，这种零效应，这种没有差异是真的吗？还是它以我们测量事物的方式表现出来？一些高调的公司，包括Facebook和Twitter，已经宣布他们将允许员工即使在紧急情况结束后也永久在家工作。你认为我们从现在开始会看到全职远程办公的公司数量有显著的永久性增加吗？
companies that offer full-time telework from now on? I do. Yes, I think that tech companies, for sure, sort of at the forefront of this, but I think it's going to be the wave of the future. I think it's going to be the new normal, maybe not full-time remote work. I think some companies will do that, But I think a lot of companies will start to let people at least work some of the time remotely. There's a lot of benefits to that from the organization standpoint. I think about it from a real estate standpoint, right? If you have a full remote workforce, you can spend a lot less money on the real estate in your central office, right? You don't have to have space for everybody to work all the time.
会的。是的，我认为科技公司肯定处于这一趋势的前沿，但我认为这将是未来的浪潮。我认为这将是新常态，也许不是全职远程工作。我认为一些公司会这样做，但我认为很多公司将开始让人们至少部分时间远程工作。从组织的角度来看，这有很多好处。我从房地产的角度考虑它，对吧？如果你拥有全职远程员工，你可以在中央办公室的房地产上少花很多钱，对吧？你不需要有空间让每个人一直工作。
And I think it can become a really nice recruiting tool. But the downsides to it are it does. there's some evidence to suggest when you have a full-time remote workforce. It does change the dynamic of the organization and that strong organizational culture and strong identification that people have within an organization is harder to get. So I think companies like Twitter and Facebook right now announcing that, they're so big, perhaps one won't hit them. But for smaller companies, I think you have to really consider how this is going to affect
而且我认为它可以成为一个非常好的招聘工具。但它的缺点是它确实存在。有一些证据表明，当你拥有全职远程员工时。它确实改变了组织的动态，人们在组织内拥有的那种强大的组织文化和强烈的认同感更难获得。所以我认为像Twitter和Facebook现在宣布这一点，他们太大了，也许不会受到影响。但对于较小的公司，我认为你必须真正考虑这将如何影响
your culture and your practices moving forward. Yeah, and I think the innovation question is probably legitimate as well. If you're not sort of rubbing elbows with people on a regular basis and bumping into them in the lunchroom or the bathrooms or wherever you might serendipitously run into somebody that you work with and you might just toss out an idea and then boom, here we go. Yeah, absolutely. And I think that's the big thing that's brought up a lot. That's why I think that a partial remote workforce is really the way to go thinking about, okay, so if I work, let's say, two days from home, then I can think about the tasks that are best done at home where I don't need an eruption. You know, I really just need to be focused for a period of time. And then the days when I am in the office, I can reserve for the times when we need to focus on innovation or other things like that. So I think there's some ways that you could combine remote work to still allow for that time of innovation. But I agree with the full-time remote work. It does out of challenge. Any other predictors for how this pandemic is going to change workplaces? One thing that I'm, I don't know if it's so much of a prediction as a hope, but I, as a work family scholar, I think that it's been interesting because of the ubiquitous use
你未来的文化和实践。是的，我认为创新问题可能也是合理的。如果你不是定期与人“擦肩而过”，在午餐室或洗手间或任何你可能偶然遇到一起工作的人的地方碰到他们，你可能只是抛出一个想法，然后砰，我们就开始了。是的，绝对。而且我认为这是经常被提出的重大事情。这就是为什么我认为部分远程员工队伍确实是前进的方向，考虑，好的，如果我工作，比如说，两天在家，那么我可以考虑最适合在家完成的任务，在那里我不需要中断。你知道，我真的只需要专注一段时间。然后我在办公室的日子，我可以留给我们需要专注于创新或其他类似事情的时候。所以我认为有一些方法可以结合远程工作，仍然允许那种创新时间。但我同意全职远程工作。它确实带来了挑战。还有其他关于这场疫情将如何改变工作场所的预测吗？我不知道这是否算是一个预测，更像是一个希望，但我，作为一名工作家庭学者，我认为这很有趣，因为无处不在地使用
of Zoom and other technologies like that, co-workers have gotten a glimpse into each other's homes in their lives in a way that they hadn't before. And in a lot of cases, I think they've seen children running around in the background. So what I hope this will do is make both managers and other employees a little bit more understanding of people with families. Sort of saying, okay, this person still managed to get their job done, but look at kind of the chaos they had running around behind them.
Zoom和其他类似的技术，同事们以一种他们以前没有的方式窥见了彼此的家和生活。在很多情况下，我认为他们看到了孩子们在背景中跑来跑去。所以我希望这将做的是让经理和其他员工对有家庭的人多一点理解。有点像说，好的，这个人仍然设法完成了他们的工作，但看看他们身后跑来跑去的混乱。
sort of recognizing like it is tough it is a tough balancing act and and and the notion that we the ideal worker is someone who has no family and puts everything into work hoping we'll start to see a little bit of the erosion of that would be understanding that hey people actually are their whole self there's a whole side of them outside of work that I think was exposed a little bit more yeah during time well this has been great really interesting stuff dr shockly I'm looking forward to seeing the results of the National Science Foundation study that you're doing. Yes, and we've made it, actually, as part of the grant, the first thing we're going to do is publish the results for a mass media audience, not academic results. So we're going to get those out as quick as we can, and they'll be hopefully very digestible and very actionable.
有点认识到，这确实很艰难，这是一个艰难的平衡行为，而且我们认为理想的员工是一个没有家庭并将一切投入到工作中的人的观念，希望我们将开始看到这一点的一点点侵蚀，即理解，嘿，人们实际上是他们的完整自我，在工作之外有他们的一面，我认为这在疫情期间暴露得更多一点。是的，好吧，这很棒，非常有趣的事情，肖克利博士。我很期待看到你正在做的国家科学基金会研究的结果。是的，我们已经做到了，实际上，作为资助的一部分，我们要做的第一件事是为大众媒体受众发布结果，而不是学术结果。所以我们将尽快把它们拿出来，希望它们非常易于消化且非常可操作。
Great. Wow, that sounds wonderful. Well, thank you again. I want to say the American Psychological Association has resources and tipsheets available on our website for help in navigating work. telework and the pandemic. So visit us at APA.org. You can also find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.spokenof psychology.org. And you can subscribe to our podcast on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And while you're out there, please give us a rating. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wyerson. Our sound editor and engineer is Chris Kondyyan.
太棒了。哇，听起来太好了。好吧，再次感谢你。我想说美国心理学会在我们的网站上有资源和提示表，可以帮助处理工作、远程办公和疫情。所以请访问我们的网站 APA.org。你也可以在我们的网站 www.spokenof psychology.org 上找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。你可以在 Apple、Stitcher 或任何你获取播客的地方订阅我们的播客。当你收听时，请给我们评分。如果你有关于未来播客的评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件给我们 speaking of psychology at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·怀尔森制作。我们的声音编辑和工程师是克里斯·康迪扬。
For the American Psychological Association, thank you for listening. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
代表美国心理学会，感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。